ya ha pasado un lustro Este martes se
cumplen cinco años del asesinato de la
diputada brasileña Mariel y Franco una
mujer afrodescendiente lesbiana y
procedente de las favelas de Río de
Janeiro cuya muerte conmocionó a Brasil
y al mundo entero por su defensa
acérrima de los Derechos Humanos
amnistía internacional aprovechó la
efeméride para denunciar la impunidad de
la justicia brasileña con el caso para
el que todavía no se han identificado a
los autores intelectuales por su parte
el gobierno de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva del que hace parte su hermana
Ariel Y como ministra por la igualdad
racial urgió al congreso votar una
propuesta para que esta jornada se
considere el Día Nacional de Mariel y
Franco y el enfrentamiento a la
violencia política de género y raza dado
todo el marco legal presentado y la
trayectoria de Mariel y Franco y su
brutal asesinato como representante
política el proyecto de ley en cuestión
sería otro paso normativo concreto para
garantizar la participación de las
mujeres en la política de manera libre y
segura Franco fue asesinada el 14 de
marzo de 2018 junto a su conductor a la
salida de un evento Público de mujeres
afro en el centro de Río desde entonces
ha habido escasos avances en la
investigación en 2019 las autoridades
arrestaron a dos ex agentes acusados de
serlos perpetradores materiales del
Crimen Sin embargo ninguno de ellos ha
sido juzgado condenado
[Música]
en Brasil desde hace cinco años miles de
personas salen a las calles de este día
para conmemorar a la diputada en
diferentes eventos por su memoria